皆さんは日本がで聞いたことありますか
日本がではありませんよ日本画です
私はその漢字で表記する
日本画ではなくてカタカナで表記する
日本がというものを描いています
日本がというのは昔の伝統的な絵画の中に
いわば現代の風俗が紛れ込んだような作品です
日本がには三つの大きな柱があります
まずは伝統絵画の技法で描くということ
それから
現在の日本の姿を描くということ
そして最後に諧謔思って描く
ということです
諧謔という言葉は最近使われなくなった古い言葉ですのでピンと来ない方も
いらっしゃるかもしれませんけれども
現代の言葉で言い表すならば
例えばユーモアとかそれとかおかしみとか言い換えてもいいかもしれません
また古典絵画というものに関してももしかしたら縁の薄い方もこの中にはいらっしゃる
かもしれませんが
私は古典絵画の中であるいは古典美術の中で一番好きなリンパというのは
そうですね桃山時代からあるいは江戸時代初期からずっと400年以上にわたって日本
人がそして特にここ
京都の人たちが楽しんできた美術の様式です
リンパというのは
そうです絵画とそれからデザインの両方の要素を備えているため今の私たちにも非常に
馴染み深いものになっています
例えば現代でも
このように着物や帯のデザインに使われたりあるいは
器のデザインに使われたりします
まあこの器に関しては伝統的なものではなくて私がデザインしているので
あひるちゃんが泳いじゃったりしていますけれども
まあこういうふうに私の作品というのは伝統会があるいは伝統美術をベースに現代の
視点を取り入れた新しい作風を模索していますそれが日本がというものです
私がこの日本がを思いついたのは
この京都の町並みが影響しているんです
いや嬉しいちょっと笑ってもらえた少しみんなちょっとほぐれてきましたかね
私は大学から京都に来たんですけれども
京都に来る前までは皆さんと同じように京都っていうのは伝統文化を強く守っている
土地柄だっていうイメージを持っていました
ところがまあ京都に実際に住むようになってからはそれとはまた違うイメージも持ち
ました
もちろん京都というのは伝統的な土地ではあります
ですけれども一方で日本の中で言うと比較的人口規模の多い大都市でもあるんですね
でさらにへ
まあ都市の規模の割りに大学が非常に多くあります
若い人が数多く住んでます
おそらくそのせいだと思うんですけれどもコンビニエンスストアであるとか
ファーストフードのお店もたくさんありますつまり京都の町並みというのは伝統的な
建造物道
それから
まあ現代的な建築が両方共存していて非常に複雑なランドスケープを生み出している
わけですね
でまぁ京都に住むようになってから私はまあ
伝統文化が大好きでしたのでお休みの日になると寺社仏閣を散歩がてら見学しに行って
いました
確かあれも大学3年生ぐらいのある日だったと思います
その日も午前中寺社仏閣の見学に出かけまして
その後まあお腹が空いたのでお昼ごはんを食べようということになりました
ただまあ学生だったんでまあなり文学性など
まああまり裕福じゃなかったせいもありまして簡単に済ませようと思って近くの
ファーストフードのチェーン店に入ったんです
でまぁファーストフードのチェーン店でしかも一番安いハンバーガーのセットを食べ
ながら
まあ自分のことに自分でツッコミを入れるというかあの自虐的にですね
自分の子と苦笑いしたんですけれどもだって皆さん想像してくださいよ
12時間前まで
非常に伝統的で日本的で荘厳な空間にいたのに今はファーストフードのチェーン店で
ハンバーガー食べていると
これって何なんだと思ったんですけれども
そこでひらめいたんですこれってもしかして作品になるかもしれないって
それで出来上がったのが
この作品ですね
はい
まあこのことがきっかけで私はまあ今の日本の生活というのが伝統的なものと現代的な
ものあるいは日本的な文化と西洋的な文化あるいは他の世界の文化と横断しながら今の
日本の生活が行われているということに改めて気がついたんです
混ざり合った文化というのの例を挙げるとキリがないんですけれども
たとえば食事の話をしましょう
私は今朝朝食にパンとコーヒーを食べました
まあシリアルもちょっと食べたかもしれないですねで
お昼ご飯はパスタを食べたりそれからラーメンを食べたりすることもあります
だけれどもまぁ夜になってくると急にこうあったかい白ご飯とみそ汁が恋しくなる事
って皆さんありませんか
なんかを私は結構そういうタイプなのでまあそういうふうに食文化も入り乱れているな
というふうに感じるんです
で食の世界だけではなくて当然すんの場所もそういう風になっています
今日は若い方もたくさんいらっしゃっていると思いますけれども若い時は特にそうなん
ですけれども
まあ例えば和室の部屋にですね机とテーブルとベッドを入れて洋風にして生活をしてみ
たり
あるいは逆に近代的なフローリングの家に住んでるのに
西洋の方のように靴のまま家にあがるのではなく畳のお家と同じようにちゃんと玄関で
靴を抜いて生活をするというようなことを
今の我々日本人は行っています
まあそういうふうにまあ日本の生活を描き出すということを始めた
日本がなんですけれどもこっからはもう少し詳しく
日本がについてどのように出来上がってきたかも含めてお見せしましょう
こちらは伝統的なまあ金びょうぶにの末に見えるところに信号と飛行機が描かれてい
ます
まあ信号を待つっていうダジャレですね
薬って感じですねごめんなさいはいえーとそれからこちらは桜と信号と飛行機が
祀るの代わりに飛行機が描かれた作品です
まあこういうふうに餌にしてみると今笑っていただきましたし少し不思議な光景かなと
思うかもしれないんですけれどもこの景色というのは実際の景色を
ベースに書いた作品ですこの作品を描く前にへ
取材をした写真をちょっと見てみましょう
このような末の横に信号であったり
桜の横に信号がはっきりと見えると思います
まぁ実際の私たちの住んでる景色というのもこのように混じり合っているということが
一目で見てわかっていただけるんじゃないかなと思います
こちらは年末年始図屏風ですまぁ年末にはクリスマスそして年明けると正月を祝いする
という日本のまあ生活習慣について描いた作品です
また最近は企業やキャラクターとのコラボレーションも増えてきました
昨年は琳派400年記念祭ということで京都を中心に盛り上がりましたがこちらは
リンパの代表的な図柄である
風神雷神図屏風を任天堂のスーパーマリオブラザーズのマリオとルイージに置き換えた
作品です
マリオ&ルイージず業務ですまあキャラクターっていうのも今の
まあ生活には欠かせない文化になってますね
それから日本画をかけ始めてからもう一つ私が体験した
大事なことというのがありますそれはこの混ざり合った文化の中で生活しているという
のは何も私たち日本人だけではないんだよということです2012年に展覧会で
オーストラリアのシドニー訪れた時のことです
まあ今日と同じように自分の作品についての講演会を依頼された私はまあ日本の
混ざり合った文化を表現するために日本画を描いていますという原稿を用意して
シドニーに来ました
ところがシドニーの街に行ってみると日本のキャラクターである
キティちゃんやポケモンが街中にあふれていたんです
現代の
世界というのはグローバルの世界というのは文化がどんどんと混じり合っていくという
ことになっています
私はその混じり合うということが悪いとは思っていません
ある文化がありそこの上に新しい文化が乗っかってきます
その時にまあ新しく来た文化というのは古いほうの文化とこう交ざり合いながらさらに
新しい文化が出来上がってきます
その時に重要なのは古い文化の方が新しい文化のフィルターを通り抜けて
変容していくというところなんです
伝統文化というとずーっと長い間変わらないものあるいはこれから先も変わら変わら
ない物っていうイメージを抱く方がいらっしゃるかもしれませんが実際には
ずーっとその時代その時代で変わってきたからこそ文化というのは引き継がれてきまし
た
日本で考えてみても縄文弥生
平安なら鎌倉室町あるいは江戸というふうに
文化は変わってきましたし
もちろん近代日本になってからも明治大正昭和と平成では文化が変わってきたのは皆
さんお分かりだと思います
伝統文化が変わっていくことに関してそのことをあまり肯定的に考えない方々というの
もたくさんいらっしゃると思いますが私はその変化そのものを楽しみたいというふうに
思っていますなぜならば
文化というのは変化することこそその本質だからです
また変化していくことと同じように大切なことは
実は過去の文化とどのようにつながっているかということです
その土地その土地あるいはその分かその分かで迂闊
受け継がれてきた文化というのは
いわば自分たちのルーツあるいは伝統と言い換えても良いものです
現代の表現というものがそのルーツとか伝統とどのようにつながっているのかという
ことが現在問われているのではないでしょうか
樹木は目に見えている地上の部分と同じぐらい大きな根っこが地面の中に隠れている
からこそ
枝葉をどんどんどんどん伸ばしていくことができます
私も
樹木がどんどん枝葉を伸ばして成長するようにこの変化していく日本あるいは
時代とともに移り変わる社会を表現していきたい
roots
伝統というところにしっかりと根を張りながらさらに枝葉を伸ばしていく
これからの日本がにぜひ皆さん期待をしていてください
ありがとうございました